well how do we make sure people with
covet 19 are still getting fed while in
quarantine not everyone can have family
and friends close by
so that's where the kova 19 food
distribution program comes in
8 news dow reporter madison kimbrough
spoke with assemblyman edgar flores
about the program and about how you can
get involved
folk are getting sick and they're in
quarantine
how are we going to make sure they're
still getting their essential food
because if we don't they're still going
to go to the grocery store and it's
going to become a hub
for spreading la bonita market puentes
las vegas nevada hispanic legislative
caucus nevada black legislative caucus
mi familia voda and several other
organizations and private donors
have come together to create the covet
19 food distribution program
la unita supermarket we have to thank
them
they dedicate like 20 of their
employees every monday morning to
prepping the boxes to bring in the
produce to bringing this to bringing
that and the items delivered are
specially crafted for each individual
and family ensuring that the items given
will be used
you have milk you have meat you have
eggs juice sometimes you get some
cleaning supplies in there
fresh produce one of the things we
didn't want is
you're in the middle of a pandemic
you're going through a very difficult
time
the last thing we want you to do is not
feel like yourself at home
and what you cook is part of almost of
your cultural identity we want to try to
create a box for different types of
cuisine
that will be authentic to that family
every monday morning at 9 00 a.m
deliveries go out
and there's always a need for delivery
drivers if you're interested in
volunteering the program has been known
to go beyond county lines and make stops
in places like pahrump and mesquite too
reporting in las vegas madison kimbrough
8 news now
madison thank you if you want to help
out or you need help yourself we have
information on how to reach out post it
to 8newsnow.com